let me just say a brief word about
Hillsdale which is a campus of never
visited one of the things I do at the
wall street journal is I hire our annual
intake of summer interns we call them
the Bartley fellows after the late great
Robert Bartley the longtime editor of
The Wall Street Journal and we get about
200 applications overwhelmingly from Ivy
League schools and every year I hire
five people and typically from the pool
of five every other year we will hire
one person to join the staff of the wall
street journal editorial page and the
last person we hired for this position
was a young woman Kate Batchelder class
of 2013 so I've come to know about
Hillsdale not only because she's an
enthusiastic alumnus of the place but
because she probably typifies certainly
exemplifies what seemed to me the
virtues of the school she writes
extremely well she thinks deeply she
cares about first principles as a result
she's capable of connecting the dots
because she knows where the dots are to
begin with which is not necessarily true
of graduates of other schools that whom
I encounter so I just want to commend
you and there must be students scattered
here and there Hillsdale students in the
audience either at the kirby center here
in Washington or back in Michigan the
bart my fellowship it's the best summer
internship on the planet it's hard to
get into but I run it so we urge you to
let me urge you to apply because we need
smart young people and they are in
incredibly short supply also because the
one of the things I've discovered in
writing my first book is that you are in
your own book entrepreneur of course I
commend my book that comes out in
November I have a wonderful blur from
George Shultz who still very much as his
mind beautifully in tact well into his
90s he had only one he said it's a great
book he said the problem your book is
book is titled American retreat the new
isolation isolationism and the coming
global disorder I signed the contract
for this book two years ago he said it
should be called the current global
disorder but because of publishing
schedules that that train has left has
left the station long ago now what I
want to talk to you about today is the
foreign policy divided in the GOP and
this seems to me a much more worthwhile
topic than talking about the foreign
policy divide in the United States I
have a colleague home in Jenkins whose
columns I commend to your attention
right to the business world colleague
but Holman has a wonderful line he says
there are certain arguments that vanish
in the presence of thought and having
arguments these days with my friends on
the Democratic or progressive or liberal
side is to have an argument which
vanishes in the presence of thought yes
we will strike a deal with Iran and the
Iranians will keep their side of the
bargain yes we will set reset relations
with Russia because after all what the
Russians want most of all is to be
integrated into a modern economy led by
the United States and the European Union
yes we will have a progressive
relationship with the Chinese because
the Chinese after all are interested in
a peaceful rise in East Asia and the
rest of the world and so we needn't
bother about the fact that they are
silently but very clearly attempting to
take
over the South China Sea yes the tide of
war is receding and we are going to
continue to do some more nation-building
at home because after all foreign policy
is as a foreign policy and domestic
policy are zero sum games and if we just
extricate ourselves from these horrible
places in the Middle East and the rest
of the world we can focus on building a
21st century infrastructure and health
care of its fit for everyone these are
not serious arguments they're not
interesting arguments their arguments
that you have to wage because as Ross
Thomas once said once you have nearly
once you have all the fools in town on
your side you practically won but
they're not intellectually interesting
arguments and so one of the reasons I
wanted to talk about the GOP the foreign
policy divide in the GOP is because it
is an intellectually interesting
argument and it does raise first
principles fundamental principles
constitutional principles on either side
of a debate that has been waged sort of
sotto voce for many years but is now
coming very fully into view and I would
offer to start this to start these
remarks I would offer the 2013 was the
year in which if you will the San
Andreas Fault within the foreign policy
establishment of the Republican Party
became Viet visible it was the year when
it began to shape we began to see that
there were serious fundamental
differences and that either then both
sides of this debate had politically
substantive leaders spokesman champions
who were going to take these positions
to the American people to the Republican
electorate and make the case for them
and make the case for them in terms
which all of us in this room however you
come down on it would recognize this
identifiably conservative identifiably
constitutionalist identifiably in touch
with the broad traditions of american
form of
foreign policy what were those three
events in 2013 early in the year the
Republican Party had a fundamental
debate about the virtues of the budget
sequester what mattered most to our
national security wasn't a deal with the
Democrats that would at last at least
start to bring down our over spending at
the federal level at the cost of making
sure that hat were at the cost of half
of those cuts coming on the back of the
military was that a sacrifice worth
bearing and that was an argument that
divided Republicans very very seriously
it was one of I remember when we were
talking about it within the Editorial
Board of The Wall Street Journal it was
one one of these times when when two
sides sort of emerged in a group that
usually is in harmony on on these on
these basic issues how seriously could
you cut the defense budget could you
take risks with defense at the expense
of finances of course I quote that line
because and I quoted it to some of my
colleagues on the other side of this
argument because that line comes from
Neville Chamberlain who in 1938 said you
know I would take a conscious chi I
consciously chose to take risks risks
with defenses instead of finances so
there was this this debate within the
party on the merits of the budget
sequester and at the time in early 2013
of course this is before the visible
advent of Isis the invasion of Ukraine
threats to the Baltic States and so on
the side that really won that argument
politically was the side that was in
favor of a budget sequester second thing
that happened and this was very striking
was the debate with among Republicans on
Edward Snowden and what he had done and
you will remember that when Snowden
defected to Hong Kong and then over to
Russia he did have very visible
defenders not simply where you would
expect them in the ACLU
ages of the nation and the New York
Times and The Guardian and so on but one
of his defenders was congressman Justin
Justin Amash from state michigan who
call said that Edward Snowden he
described him as a whistleblower Rand
Paul senator from Kentucky said yes mr.
Snowden had broken his oath to his
employers but on the other hand he also
had an oath to the Constitution and he
compared Edward Snowden to none other
than Martin Luther King jr. he said that
what Snowden had done was in a betrayal
was it treason it was an act of civil
disobedience and I think that within
some quarters of the Republican Party in
fact growing quarters of the Republican
Party that feeling was widely shared
their is polling to show that now an
absolute majority of males of men in
America who self-identify as Republican
are telling pollsters that the United
States is going too far in suppressing
civil liberties this poll is from 20
2013 but it's an interesting thing to
imagine that the same Republican Party
that only ten years ago had an Edward
Snowden emerged back then would almost
surely have been in lockstep in
condemning what he had done as an act of
treason or espionage or betrayal it's
suddenly what he had done was at a
minimum dividing dividing the party the
person who brought the suit in federal
court to to end the metadata collection
program of the National Security Agency
this is the collection of telephone
metadata you know what what phone
numbers place calls to what other what
other phone numbers is not another than
Larry Klayman very active figure in the
Tea Party so this was a second major
debate happening just months after the
budget sequester debate again it showed
visible fault lines within the thinking
of the Republicans are we a party that
is fundamentally about civil liberties
about privacy about keeping a high wall
between what the state can see and do
when it
to our private mods in our private
business or is security integral to what
we mean by civil liberties is it in fact
security the fundamental civil liberty
after all because if you don't have
security if you haven't solved the
problems that Hobbes had to solve you
can't get to the problems that lock then
have to solve a few decades later in the
third debate which was quite interesting
was the debate following the attack by
Bashar Assad's forces in Damascus using
sarin gas or some other kind of chemical
weapon that led to the death of a
thousand at least a thousand or so
civilians and this again was a
fascinating debate on many grounds one
of which was a simple political debate
can anyone seriously trust this
president to be an effective commander
in chief under any circumstances but
there was a deeper de vie for instance
the debate as to whether Congress ought
to be consulted whether Congress needed
to authorize an air strike to carry out
attacks on Assad for course ambling
across Obama's notorious infamous and
utterly erased red lines now for 40
years the Republic 40 years the
Republican Party and conservatives had
made the argument that the War Powers
Resolution of 1973 which have been
passed against a politically crippled
Richard Nixon was not constitutional
that they did not believe in it they
would not honor it that Congress did not
in fact have to authorize every single
military strike congress after all did
not authorize the invasion of Grenada
Congress did not authorize the bombing
of Libya in 1986 Congress was given five
hours notice by President George HW Bush
that he intended to invade Panama none
of this disturbed conservatives or
Republicans at the time even though it
rankled kind of usual suspects in the
liberal world but something we're having
this major debate about the legitimate
extent of presidential powers as come
nourin chief against the obligations of
Congress to be the body of government
that authorizes or that declares wars so
2013 turned out to be a pivotal year and
we started to see these fault lines
beginning to emerge and how would you
define those phones well if you're
talking about a matter of budgets I
would say the debate goes between what i
would call small government
conservatives and big military
conservatives now there are people who
believe in a big military for the
military and small government house
where and there are people who believe
you know vice versa think that
government should generally be be small
but you have to make allowances defense
being a constitutionally legitimate
function of government but you can see
these differences beginning to emerge
and nowhere more clearly than when Rand
Paul Senator Rand Paul says look we have
750 bases around the world our military
is in 130 countries we are bankrupting
ourselves and adventures overseas when
we should be Marshall marshaling our
energies because after all you can't
have strength abroad unless you have
strength at home now I happen to know
and I'm going to tip my hand in this
debate by saying that that is exactly
what Barack Obama is saying except
Barack Obama wants to retreat from
America's overseas commitments for the
sake of big government whereas Rand Paul
wants to retreat from those overseas
commitments for the sake of small
government but I think this is a this
nonetheless as a fundamental difference
in this in this divided small government
conservatives against big military
conservatives people who think that a
large military is fundamental not only
to America's interests but also in some
sense fundamental to America's identity
now there is also a moral component to
this divide and I would put the question
this way are we is America fundamentally
a land of liberty or are we a nation of
liberators are we a country or are we a
cause
it's an important question that we need
to ask ourselves it's a fundamental
question are we a city on the hill that
is principally interested in minding our
own business maximizing our own
liberties showing what Liberty can do
but in the words of John Quincy Adams we
do not go abroad in search of monsters
to destroy we are the well-wishers of
the freedom of all we are the vindicator
only of our own he said that for his
July 4th Independence Day address in
1825 which was the first year of his of
his presidency and by the way to all of
you with kids make them know dates
because if you know dates and if you
know who was president when you'll be
able to connect those dots dates matter
information matters don't look it up on
Wikipedia have it at your disposal so
are we a land of liberty are we the land
of john of john quincy adams or are we a
land of liberators is our identity
really not simply on battlefields like
Gettysburg or Bunker Hill but also a
checkpoint charlie and pan moon John
does that identify does that does that
it does that is that the core of our
identity the country that went abroad
and proved that it was the last best
hope on earth not only for ourselves but
for others who brought freedom to South
Koreans and tried to bring freedom to
the Vietnamese who made sure that Europe
didn't crumble in the aftermath of the
Second World War that continues to
defend vital and embattled democracies
like Israel and Taiwan are we that
country this is a fundamental question
soul and land of liberty or land of
liberators and this seems to me also to
be an important dividing line between
the two sides in in this debate and
again i should say these are these are
difficult questions I'm not I'm not sort
of i'm not trying to offer you a sort of
a facile false you know obama asked
false dilemmas
here you know do we want to steal from
Aunt Sally are we going to be a nation
of nice people this is kind of debate at
the level of Obama sorry that's on the
side then there's an ideological
component which is are we essentially
you know what is what is our world view
is it what comes to be known as a kind
of isolationist or Neil isolationists or
are we internationalists or
neoconservatives one of the things that
I try to do in this book because the
title the new isolationism is in it is I
think it's important not that I agree
with it but I think it is important to
give the isolationists the intellectual
respect that they are do because it was
not an insignificant movement it is not
an insignificant tradition and is not a
stupid tradition it is a fundamental
tradition one might even say it is the
default tradition of American foreign
policy george washington says the great
rule of our conduct for us in regard to
foreign nations is in extending our
commercial in is in extending our
commercial relations to have with them
is little political connection as
possible that's George Washington in his
farewell address Thomas Jefferson says
peace commerce and honest friendship
with all entangling alliances with none
Robert Taft as late as the nineteen
early 1940s Lee and then and then again
after the war set for many years the
leaders of this country every party have
asserted that America should never go to
war unless an attack is made on this
continent now this is somewhat amusing
coming from the son of the man who was
at one point the governor-general of the
Philippines somehow we did that but um
but what I'm trying to say is that this
is a serious intellectual tradition and
if you look at for instance who composed
the America first committee which is now
you know derided is horrible committee
who is on it Sinclair Lewis EE cummings
Potter Stewart the future Supreme Court
Gerald Ford future President of the
United States so this is a tradition
that deserves a measure of respect and
not only it deserves a measure of
respect not least because I think that
when the United States does not face
extraordinary pressing international
circumstances it's who we want to be
isolationism expresses a certain kind of
American asst and so we have to think
about it as a serious point of view and
not just as a kind of a parochial or
prejudicial point of view and against
that there's this other tradition of
internationalism which has essentially
been if you will the foreign policy that
dare not speak its name because America
has in fact been going abroad in search
of monsters to destroy from the from the
Barbary pirates all the way up until the
Pirates in Iraq and Syria right now and
many enemies in between it's just that
we are we pretend or we tell ourselves
that this is not really you know the
real the real American tradition so
that's that's that's that's another
another question that needs to be faced
and finally there's a question of what
is really the threat to the United
States ask yourselves this what is a
bigger threat to America today number
one the prospect that Iran will get a
nuclear weapon number two exploding
federal deficits or state and city
bankruptcies what's the bigger threat I
don't know what the answer to that is
you would obviously answer well they're
both big threats but what is the bigger
threat these are the sort of questions
that I think are important to ask if we
are going to begin to grapple with
having a serious foreign policy and if
we are going to be able to come up with
foreign policy solutions that begin to
make sense and make sense for us now in
light of where we have been in the last
20 years let me talk a little bit about
the foreign policy moment that we are in
okay after you know 1988 actually
January of 1989 George HW
gave an inaugural address which is
really worth reading it's one of the
better inaugural addresses I think ever
given product is Peggy Noonan wrote it
but that's another story someone at the
Wall Street Journal had to end it but he
said in that speech the day of the
dictator is done we know what works
freedom works and that was a very
apropos thing to say in 1989 when it was
clear that the Soviet Union was
collapsing when it was clear that the
people in Poland or in Hungary or
throughout Eastern Europe were yearning
for freedom that the collapse of the
berlin wall was just a few months into
the future and then throughout the 1990s
this seemed obvious the thesis that we
had reached an end of history not as a
question of events but as a matter of
ideology in which there was common
agreement that the only sustainable
political formula that worked or could
work for man was liberal democracy this
was this was sort of the shared conceit
of most most Americans people around the
world Democrats as well as as
conservatives and so we began to pursue
a new kind of foreign policy in the
United States we were no longer pursuing
a foreign policy that was about keeping
nightmares at bay during the Cold War
our greatest nightmare was a nuclear
exchange with the Soviet Union so our
entire foreign policy was organized
around how do we make sure that we don't
have a nuclear exchange with the Soviets
and at the same time don't allow them to
essentially conquer our allies or
conquer the world Cold War foreign
policy was about keeping nightmares at
bay suddenly after 1989 foreign policy
becomes how do we make our dreams come
true for two very different things so
Bill Clinton begins to pursue a foreign
policy based on the concept of the peace
process the idea that if you just bring
Bill Clinton into a room all reasonable
people will agree
that in a nutshell was US foreign policy
for almost a decade extraordinarily
extraordinarily enough that America
American goodwill American money could
essentially bulldoze the way to get past
misunderstanding past conflict so you
had a peace process in Israel peace
process in Northern Ireland get a peace
process that Susan Rice engineered
between Eritrea and Ethiopia worked out
great another peace process in Liberia
which in which she brought in Foday
Sankoh into government this is bud wait
sorry this is an aside but the National
Security Advisor of the United States
once engineered a peace process which
brought a man whose principal business
before entering this peace process was
hacking people's arms off and gouging
out their eyes to be vice president of a
country this was sorry this was Sierra
Leone not not not Liberia anyway she's
now the National Security Advisor but
that's that's another story so you had
this foreign policy from Clinton and
then you had the bushes and in a sense
much of the Bush Doctrine reflected the
premises the philosophical premises of
the Clinton years why was that because
Bush believed and said in his second
inaugural address that it was possible
it was the policy of the United States
to end tyranny in every culture in our
time and I would submit that the common
premise is a ruse obion premise Rousseau
tells us that man is born free and yet
everywhere he is in chance so it simply
is the policy of the United States to go
around breaking those chains the chains
that Saddam Hussein did imposes a change
that the Iranian regime had imposed
there was more commonality between the
Clinton doctrine the Clinton foreign
policy and george w bush's foreign
policy at least in the freedom agenda
sense than most people recognize this
was a foreign policy about making dreams
come true and so we had this
extraordinarily ambitious foreign policy
and you saw it play out when it came to
the war in Iraq now what was the problem
with the war in Iraq well there were two
several reasons to go to war in Iraq
number one was to make an example of
Saddam Hussein to say this guy is a
serial lawbreaker who if he doesn't have
weapons of mass destruction will
certainly want to get weapons of mass
destruction should he be given the
opportunity to do so he's invaded all of
his neighbor's he's terrorized his
people and it is the goal of a great
power like the United States to insist
that a certain point enough is enough
that we will make an example of Saddam
Hussein and we will make an example of
him not only for the sake of Iraq but
for all the other dictators around the
world and notice people say well we
never found weapons of mass destruction
in Iraq but moammar gadhafi gave up his
weapons of mass destruction program
exactly five days after Saddam Hussein
was pulled from his spider hole in
December of 2003 so that was one reason
to go into Iraq you might call it the
Cheney doctrine I'd like to rehabilitate
it at some point in the future column
and then the second reason wasn't to
make an example Saddam Hussein it was to
make Iraq exemplary and so we won the
war in Iraq in three weeks at a cost of
139 American lives and then we spent
seven years trying to make Iraq a
pluralist tolerant multicultural
multi-denominational democracy with so
many women in the parliament freedom
rights for all and that turned into a
seven-year Fiasco so because we went
from a foreign policy that began as an
act of making sure nightmares can't
can't happen and ended up becoming a
foreign policy of trying to make dreams
come true that we came that we that we
came to grief instead of trying to be
the world's policeman we try to be the
world's priests presser the business of
saving souls and changing hearts the
policeman stands right there he
reassures good people he deters people
who are tempted to do evil and he
punishes the wicked I would offer to you
that that distinction is a distinction
worth worth worth keeping
with keeping very much in mind now what
are some of the other foreign policy
temptations for the Republican Party for
the GOP for conservatives well one is
realism now this is realism with a
capital R this is realism as it's
practiced by Henry Kissinger and Brent
Scowcroft and Jim Baker and this is a
defensible interesting worthwhile
concept theory idea for American foreign
policy Henry Kissinger was an
interesting Secretary of State the Nixon
administration achieved interesting
things when it was in when it was in
office the good thing about realism is
that realism understands that in
international relations power is the
coin of the realm we want to talk about
what Obama's foreign policy problem is
in a single sentence he thinks foreign
policy is a popularity contest he's the
guy who said hey I just won American
Idol why why isn't Putin giving me a
record contract
this is his foreign policy look I'm
popular i'm not george w bush and there
so therefore all foreign policy problems
melt away everyone likes america because
everyone likes me and then when that
didn't work out he had no plan B if you
want to understand part of the vacuum of
American foreign policy is that this
administration remains in shock that
it's no longer popular and there's
nothing beyond that it's like a beauty
queen who loses her crown so sorry for
the digression about Barack Obama these
things kind of come over me and this is
how columns columns end up being
generated generating so realists
understand it for that in foreign policy
power is the coin of the realm that's a
serious and important point to note in
foreign policy a realist would agree
with Machiavelli's maxim that when it
comes to foreign policy the best thing
to do is to develop a reputation as
Machiavelli put it to be a firm friend
and a thorough foe wonderful way of
understanding if you do nothing else
follow Machiavelli's Maxim for foreign
policy and you'll have a pretty decent
foreign policy the Obama doctrine by the
way is to be a terrible friend right to
our to our friends and to ingratiate
ourselves as much as we can with our
enemies but that's that's a this is not
what I'm here to talk about i'm talking
about that the GOP but the problem that
you have with the Kissinger's with with
the bakers and Scowcroft is is is this
razon d'etat no longer works in politics
the way it used to why because we have a
democratic politics and in a democratic
political system the people demand a
certain kind of moral accountability in
their foreign policy so we the kind of
cold-blooded realism that a kissinger
might have practiced or a baker might
have practiced negotiating with an Assad
or a mounts a tongue I don't think can
work in the 21st century
it can't work in an era when you have
instant cellphone feeds to whatever the
Assad regime may be doing at any given
moment in in homes or aleppo or one of
these these other cities so the realism
that Kissinger dick stolz in his books
and it's fascinating the realism of a
medic or a Palmerston or a Bismarck
simply doesn't work in in this century
then there's what I call the phone
realism fake realism of Rand Paul you
might see a political drift as I say in
some some of the comments on a Rand Paul
spoke and I think at a heritage
Institute but then and he said I am
neither an isolationist nor a nor a
neoconservative I am a realist now Rand
Paul is a guy who also says that he's a
Fourth Amendment conservative now if
you're Henry Kissinger aradhana pick on
dr. Kissinger but if you're a true
realist and you have a situation where
you have to take a Predator drone and
smoke someone in that table because he's
an al-qaeda terrorist and maybe kill the
people around him because it's a
successful political action you will do
that even if we're in a private hotel in
a private ballroom in the United States
because moral considerations aren't what
matter to the true realist when it comes
to the practice of international
politics or the safeguarding of national
security if you're a Fourth Amendment
conservative of course that doesn't work
because it's a violation of basic
constitutional rights so on his own
grounds Rand Paul's notion of being a
realist betrays a total ignorance of
what the concept of realist means he
also likes to say well you know I think
that I would be a president or we need a
president of foreign policy president in
the mold of Dwight Eisenhower and Dwight
Eisenhower has suddenly been reinvented
in Rand Paul's imagination as this very
reluctant practitioner of amer
I can power now Dwight Eisenhower is the
guy who came to office warning North
Korea that the United States would nuke
them unless they settled at pennridge on
he was part of the coup to overthrow the
socialist muscletech government in Iran
a year after the most of that government
he overthrew the are Bens government in
Guatemala he sent 14 or 15 thousand
Marines into Lebanon when President
Eisenhower came to power the United
States had two thousand nuclear bombs in
its arsenal by the time he left power we
had 18,000 nuclear bombs the first
nuclear submarine the first ballistic
nuclear submarine the first super
carrier the first nuclear supercarrier
the first ICBM all of our tanks the b-52
bomber which is still in our arsenal the
u-2 spy plane which is only now being
decommissioned all of that comes from
eisenhower eisenhower astoundingly is
remembered as the man who warned against
a military industrial complex he is the
man who created the military-industrial
complex so again I would only say to
Rand Paul by all means study eisenhower
follow eisenhower just know what
Eisenhower actually did so far if this
phone realism isn't really a worthy
foreign policy but it is worth worth
while studying up on what on what the
real realest are about and seeing and
seeing what they can what they can
contribute and then there is the foreign
policy a foreign policy school which is
what you might call a real neo
isolationism you know straight out
straight isolationism and this is also a
foreign policy with a real Republican
tradition Warren Harding it's
interesting when you think about it when
people think what is the best historical
analogue for Barack Obama people say
always terrible Carter Hoover James
Buchanan think about Warren Harding
except for the womanizing part
here is a president who emerges from the
opposite party and what is his promise
to the American people normal see it
sounds a lot like nation-building at
home it sounds a lot like the tide of
war is receding this is a president who
begins the process of withdrawing the
United States from the world after a
predecessor from the opposite party who
had crusade it for the United States on
also somewhat utopian principles if
george w bush has an analog in foreign
policy it's probably woodrow wilson
barack obama it's probably Warren
Harding what does Warren Harding do what
is his signal foreign policy achievement
and is the Washington Naval Treaty which
restricted the size of the u.s. Navy to
various respective tonnage asst what was
Obama's signal foreign policy
achievement in quotes during his first
term it was the New START treaty with
the Soviet Union restricting strategic
nuclear arms then we have Calvin
Coolidge Calvin Coolidge is an
interesting figure 44 American
conservatives he you know enjoys a vogue
in many respects I was reading Amity
Shlaes his excellent biography of calvin
coolidge in which she says somewhere if
I can only find this quote I can because
I can't read my own handwriting but
Coolidge basically spends his days
trying to figure out how to fend off
requests from the army to deploy more
more more planes to the Panama Canal and
for the Navy for a new battleship that
was Coolidge's form paule the foreign
policy it was minimizing the US military
for the sake of deficit deficit
reduction paying off wartime obligations
and then you had Herbert Hoover and what
was Herbert Hoover is great achievement
well there was the Washington Naval conv
excuse me Coolidge did something else he
also signed the kellogg-briand pact
which outlawed war forever a historian
once remarked wonderful Scottish
historian and i hope the scots remain in
britain a historian once remarked that
only in the age of prohibition when
Americans had convinced themselves that
they could abolish the evil of drink
through legal Fiat could something like
the kellogg-briand pact come into being
where we Americans could also convince
ourselves that we could abolish war by
legal Fiat so that was the other
Coolidge administration achievement and
finally you had Herbert Hoover who's
Secretary of State Henry Stimson had the
bright idea when he discovered that the
State Department had a cipher breaking
or code-breaking operation he shut it
down with the immortal one gentlemen do
not read one another's mail sounds a lot
a great deal like the push among civil
libertarians today to shut down the
metadata collection efforts by the
National Security Agency because a great
country like the United States should
not be reading or listening in on Angela
Merkel's phone calls or so on with tatis
mutinies very much the same thing it is
it is today so these are the sort of
alternatives that we are beginning to
look at throughout the world and all of
them are failed alternatives what should
be the right solution what is the
Goldilocks prescription for an American
a truly conservative foreign policy
going forward well let me read you a
quote from an American president and by
the way a lollipop to anyone who knows
who I don't have a lollipop it honorary
lollipop to anyone who gets who who said
is which president our true choice is
not between town between tax reduction
on the one hand and the avoidance of a
law of large federal deficits on the
other it is increasingly clear that no
matter what party is in power so long as
our national security needs keep rising
an economy hampered by restrictive tax
rates will never produce enough revenues
to balance our budgets just as it will
never produce enough jobs or enough
profits who said that you see I
I have no tricks with you guys John F
Kennedy in 1962 of the New York economic
Economic Club JFK people understood that
you don't necessarily have to make a
choice between small government and a
big military so long as you understand
that our defense budget is an essential
function of the federal government and
that our security at or rather our
prosperity at home is underwritten by
security abroad which understands that a
free training prosperous world in which
countries like Russia Iran and China are
not tempted to challenge America because
America's power is overwhelming that
that is part of what makes for our
prosperity that a big military essential
to prosperity and security is central to
civil liberty these are the sorts of
things that people need to understand
our problem with a big government
doesn't come from too much military
spending we spend a smaller proportion
on our defense today then Jimmy Carter
did when he was present in fact George W
Bush spent a smaller proportion of gdp
on defense about 5.1 percent in 2008
when Jimmy Carter did when he was
president in in in in two thousand so we
can begin to at least find some common
ground between small government
conservatives and big military
conservatives understanding that foreign
policy and domestic policy are not a
zero-sum game that security abroad means
prosperity at home the second thing that
we need to do is understand that our
goal is not to redeem the world our goal
should be to police the world now what
does it mean to be a world's policeman
and what is the most effective method of
policing the world well in 1980 22 great
American political scientists and I know
it's astonishing to finger you can be
great envy
scientist but to really great political
scientist James Q Wilson and George
Kellen wrote a very important art upon
the Atlantic magazine you can find it on
Google it's called broken windows I
commend it to your attention and there
they observed a theory of social order
they noticed that if a single window in
a neighborhood is broken pretty soon
every single other window in that
neighborhood will also be broken unless
that window is fixed very quickly what
they understood is that crime in America
wasn't happening because of root causes
poverty broken homes bad schools racism
11 sort of fury after another it was
happening because the mere appearance of
disorder fosters a deeper kind of
disorder even criminals tend to be
social conformance when they realize
that no one's looking no one's in charge
anything goes they'll act but if they
feel that someone is in charge that
people are looking they'll conform it's
a kind of it's a brilliant idea that you
you don't go from the bottom to the
surface you go from the surface to the
bottom you go from appearances to deeper
things and so they have this what they
call the broken window windows theory of
policing which was that the goal of the
police wasn't to react to crime the
fundamental goal it was to preserve the
appearance of order and the appearance
of order had to be preserved not
necessarily by prosecuting every rape
and murder all you had to do those
things but it was by prosecuting the
small things what they called the social
in civilities kid jumps a turnstile pees
on the street spray paints a subway car
with graffiti these were the things that
were causing crime these were the things
that were driving honest people out of
cities and inviting bad people into
cities and they understood this so they
write this article nineteen eighty-two
twelve years later an American mayor
named Rudy
giuliani reads this article says this
sounds like a good idea and new york
city went from having 25 hundred murders
a year to having under four hundred
murders a year it was the most
astonishing form of social regeneration
that we've ever seen in modern American
history all thanks to two great
political sciences who had a bright idea
now there is a broken windows theory for
the world and this should be the essence
of a conservative foreign policy and
what is that well you know in September
of 2013 Bashar Assad gassed his own
people there was an American red line
and we did nothing it is not an accident
comrades that within six months Vladimir
Putin was seasoned Crimea and invading
eastern Ukraine the connection between
Syria and Ukraine is not causal its
environmental there was one broken
window so someone decided to break the
next broken window and it's worth asking
ourselves who will break the third
broken window or who break the third
window well Isis you can say already
broke the window that was called a rack
the Chinese are going to become more
aggressive in the South China Sea they
nearly brought down an American an
American surveillance plane just a few
weeks ago this is going to be happening
around the world because there is a
sense of disorder so we need an American
foreign policy that understands that the
goal for America is to be the world's
policemen because there is no substitute
to us if you don't like being the cop
you're going to like it last when
Vladimir Putin is the cop or the UN is
the cop or the Chinese or the cop well
you're the cop because there is no other
cop and you don't want to live in a
neighborhood without a policeman we want
to understand that the job of the
policeman is not to go around walking
into people's homes saying fix your life
stop drinking be a better person there
are other agencies and other
institutions that may or may not do that
in the
of time but that is not the job of a
serious form of a serious foreign policy
the job of the series foreign policy is
to set some baseline rules that reassure
your friends and scare your enemies and
make sure that when those rules are
broken that there are consequences for
it and not just consequences in the form
of a UN resolution or Barack Obama
giving a speech in Brussels which is
this president's idea of consequences
that they're real consequences for them
then violations of order violations of
order are punished and punished
consistently I just want to finish very
briefly by just offering you one thought
because after all I'm really here to
sell my book to you which you may
pre-order on amazon already let me
finish with this what a conservative
foreign policy can do is maintain global
order in a way favorable to the Security
and Prosperity of our friends watchful
of the ambitions of our adversaries and
mindful of the need to keep the
country's caught in between states such
as Kuwait or Ukraine or Vietnam tilting
toward us conservative foreign policy is
in the business of shaping habits of
behavior not winning hearts and minds it
announces red lines sparingly but
enforces them unsparing it is willing to
act decisively or preventively to punish
to punish or prevent blatant
transgressions of order not as a matter
of justice but in the interests of
deterrence but it knows it cannot
possibly punish or prevent every
transgression it champions its values
consistently and confidently but it
doesn't conflate its values and its
interests it wants to let citizens go
about their business as freely and
easily as possible but it knows that
security is a prerequisite for civil
liberty not a threat to it where it can
use a finger or a hand to tilt the to
tilt the political scales of society
toward liberal democracy it will do so
but it won't attempt to tilt the scales
and places where the tilting demands all
of its weight
strength and endurance it does not waste
its energy or time chasing diplomatic
symbols its ambitions do not revolve
around the Nobel Peace Prize it prefers
liberal liberal autocracy to illiberal
democracy because the former is likely
to evolve into democracy than the latter
is to evolve into liberalism it knows
the value of hope and knows also that
economic growth based on enterprise and
the freest possible movement of goods
services capital and labor is the best
way of achieving it and it is mindful of
the claims of conscience which is
strengthened by faith but it has no
messianic messianic ambitions of its own
it prefers a predictability to
transformation the change it seeks and
promotes is evolutionary thank you very
much
you
you